it's time for the educational breakdowns
brought to you by robert hess and
fabiano carwana i'll quickly set the
tone and say we had another rui lopez
for those who've been following the
whole match and loved the opening theory
h3 was played in move one a4 was played
in move three and then yet again here in
game five bobby
yeah uh i i kind of expected that
he would try this again because magnus's
last recipe although it worked out very
well
was a bit of a objectively shaky one
when he played bishop to b7
d3
d6 knight bd2 and here he played the
remove rook to e8 and it worked out very
well for him in that game he equalized
very comfortably
but i'm sure that that dion and his team
of seconds found some ideas here yep uh
so magnus was the one to
again try to surprise yon before yeah
before yon showed his ideas in the main
lines with rook b8 here but ian was
again very well uh
very well prepared for this move he he
quickly blissed out h3
and uh and c3 and after b4 d3
he was playing very very rapidly here
robert you really liked d3 we spent a
lot of time in real time talking about
the traditional spanish structures it
was very educational let's tell
everybody why you felt i remember during
the game you were saying this was
already a good sign from your point of
view for yon yeah because he
has such a good position where black's
piece are restricted so when you have
less space you often want to make trades
and yan isn't allowing a series of mass
trades he's not handing black's pieces
good squares so i found that d3 just
trying to develop the knight to d2
reroute it to better squares on the king
side or the c4 square over there on the
queen side that this made a lot of sense
so i liked the start of this game for
jan i think d3 was a great choice he
showed good opening preparation and to
remind everybody of a critical variation
that fabi and robert were going over in
real time in terms of why as robert said
d4 is not what you want to play you
don't want to let your opponent make
trades when they have less space the key
move order after d4 is not taking here
first where the b-pawn then stands in
the way of the rook and the knights
activity but actually to play the move b
take c3 would have come from black
followed by e takes d4 if my
mouse doesn't jump around there and then
d5 as you can see with the knight coming
to e4 black's pieces are very active on
the queen side so
that didn't happen d3 was played by yon
still playing very quickly guys
after the trade in d5
you showed a critical line here fabi why
white doesn't take here and take the e5
pawn right let's do that again yeah
let's have a look at etek's d5 because
it is the most critical approach
grabbing the pawn always has to be
considered but after knight takes rook
takes and bishop to e6
uh white has very serious tactical
problems to deal with first of all the
threat of knight takes c3
there is that discovered attack from
bishop one e6 on the bishop one b3 and
also pointing out what you mentioned
earlier the rook on b8 pointing out the
bishop one b3 is very important and if
the bishop moves somewhere to escape
that threat then after bishop f6 we see
the other problem white's rook on e5 is
in the way and the c3 pawn is going to
get captured
so that's why yon didn't take it and i
noticed when yon played knight bd2 here
i noticed that magnus looked a bit
disappointed of course he must have
known about this move but i think he was
disappointed that jan was not surprised
by his opening choice with rook v8 and
he was still playing quickly i think the
main point of rp8 was to surprise his
opponent and it didn't work out and
that's why
he was probably not too happy with the
opening outcome yeah well and and it
didn't work out not just from the
practical point of view of what you're
saying and judging magnus's body
language but white was better here
starting with an idea a very important
one from robert which was queen c2
keeping the shot of bishop d5 open yeah
because black's pieces are sort of
stepping on each other's toes they're
fighting for the e7 square we mentioned
queen e7 they try to play bishop e6
because that light square bishop for
white is very powerful but queen e7
always ran into bishop d5 trying to
remove that knight you can't capture you
don't want to unleash the rook against
the queen so it felt like black was
stumbling a little bit trying to find
good moves i did like what magnus did
with h6 first making sure no peace from
why he's going to g5 and then rerouting
the knight over to the king side to g6
so this was all well played by both
sides and now was such a critical moment
where white was considered do i jump
into f5 do i play this move bishop e3
which i think is a good developing move
and then the question revolves around
knight five or eventually c4 for white
yeah and we spent a lot of time in real
time everyone looking at the critical
tactics of knight f5 and knight takes e4
which is a very common idea in these
positions and one that you have to
follow closely some variations included
knight takes h6 followed by bishop d5
where this knight is sort of pinned
because of the f7 pawns pinned to the
bishop uh we we would not get these
types of fireworks on the board boys as
much as as much as we hoped for it but
after bishop e3 and queen eight we felt
that it was reasonable
to get these fireworks maybe with c4
hashtag boom goes the dynamite fabi but
we didn't get it i liked jan's decision
to play bishop e3 rather than knight of
five despite our hopes that we would get
some crazy fireworks and potential
attacks on both kings
um but starting from this moment i think
that he played a bit too routinely yep
very logical moves you can't really
criticize rookie to d1 it slightly
improves rook from a semi close file to
to an open file
but we did mention the move c4 here was
probably a good chance
um
posing magnus some very concrete
problems how do you deal with the threat
of c5 black has to either at some point
play c5 to stop it or move the bishop
out of the way to deal with it
and none of those options seemed very
easy and that coupled with the clock
situation where magnus was significantly
down on time compared to yon
i think he would have been able to put
serious pressure on magnus if he were to
play this way so this is the first
moment i think we can talk about yon
starting to let the advantage slip and
robert quickly to tell everyone why do
both c5 and bishop b4 as although they
are responses they don't quite solve all
magnus's problems that he could have
faced right black's pieces get
discombobulated if you play c5 now the
issue is your bishop on d6 is a tall
pawn and just staring into its own pawns
which is good for defensive measures but
white can continue to be active and then
black is pushed back further and so if
you play bishop b4 you are attacking the
rook the rook slides out of the way and
then when you play c5 your bishop on b4
strained it over there on the queenside
it's defended by the pawn c5 it's
defending the pawn on c5 but the d6
squares are highlighting maybe the
knight is jumping in and maybe that
bishop can be attacked at some point
because it can't move anywhere so white
essentially operates around the bishop
and that's one critical defender missing
from the center of the board and that
could cause black some serious problems
so white did not go for that as we've
been now reviewing here rookie today one
played still as he said hard to
criticize but here comes bishop e6 which
in real time was the simplification we
knew black was playing for it's the
thematic idea magnus's moves were
literally threatening it with queen
eight
and i think we were hoping for something
more the last chance after bishop a4 and
bishop b7 was was again maybe to take on
d7 and c4 right bobby maybe well just to
back up for one second after bishop to
a4 we were somewhat hoping for the
potential fireworks with queen z8 yes
with the idea potentially of a bishop
takes h3 sacrifice because white's some
of white's pieces are a bit um removed
from the king side the queen would be a
great defender but it's not there the
light square bishop is usually a great
defender but it's it's on a4 rather than
on f1 for example so this would have
maybe led to some interest we'll show
some fun stuff just to show everybody
that we're not kidding around when we
say this was maybe very dangerous crazy
things like this where the king can't
take it because uh how's this for a for
a party
coming in at the white kings at spain
expense so there were there were very
real dangers here but alas again we
would not see those on the board yeah
instead magnus chose an understandable
and very solid move bishop d7 and after
the trade of
bishops
i don't feel like white was really
playing for significant advantage
anymore so as you mentioned instead of
knight d2 maybe white's best shot
was to take on d7 and play c4 still that
idea feels like most ambitious one
trying to gain some space in this case
it doesn't feel like black encounters
significant issues
but
it might have uh well rather than bishop
a maybe use your favorite rook to a8 to
stop rook a6
i don't feel like magnus would have been
under serious pressure here but it would
have been a bit less pleasant for him
than in the game where he really never
struggled he played quickly and
confidently and easily
maneuvered himself towards a draw
and again by the way pointed out in real
time between fabiano ifan was the nice
little point that if bishop takes a4
rook takes a4 black actually has the
cute little rook to b2 forcing the
exchange anyway because of the queen's
overwhelm and that might even be even
better for black than what happened in
the game so robert i'm going to click
through these as you give thoughts on
this end game i mean obviously we got to
a position where yon was pretending
maybe to be pushing but talk a little
bit real quick last point about magnus's
really stellar defense here yeah he just
retreated before he could go forward he
made sure that all of his bases were
covered first knight to e8 covering the
bishop on d6 and the pawn c7 uh for good
measure then he brought his knight to e6
and he protected his e5 pawn with a pawn
pawn's best friend is another pawn and
to fabiano's point that the defense here
magnus could play with his hand rather
than with his brain you want to make
your opponent think on every turn here
magnus had a very clear plan for himself
he made it work he just orchestrated it
very directly and then he put in his
knight on d6 trading his inactive knight
for these quite active white knights and
now there are not enough pieces
remaining for white to actually have any
hope for a win last really educational
point for those watching live and maybe
those checking out our recap on youtube
really nice to see the defensive effort
here you don't ever want to change your
defensive structure if you haven't
established a clear winning plan for
your opponent something like this would
have been a really good example of how
to go wrong even if you first look at
your pawn as a weakness it actually
closes the d-file and immediately gives
white long-term chances in which he
lacks so just a fun little point to take
away another reason why magnus is great
and very tough to beat he takes with the
bishop backs that thing up and suddenly
you could snapshot it
you could try to even play imaginary
chess as we were discussing put that
white king anywhere on the board and you
hardly have winning chances and so
eventually even with the d-file opening
up they've repeated moves because white
recognized the inability to make
progress and that everyone is how game
five came to an end
chess.com coverage of the 2021 v-day
world championship is brought to you by
our partners at coinbase whether you're
just thinking about making your first
crypto purchase just wanting to learn a
little bit more about the crypto
industry or if you've been doing this
thing for years and you're an
experienced trader coinbase is the place
to be
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free bitcoin just for signing
up and verifying your account today we
really encourage you to do so go check
them out at coinbase.com
[Music]
you